et de l'assurance chômage seront menées
à leur terme mais repoussée en raison de
la crise sanitaire
[Musique]
ce maître russe iana à bruxelles les 27
dirigeants européens sont réunis
possiblement jusqu'à dimanche pour
négocier le plan de relance de
l'économie européenne de 750 milliards
d'euros
des discussions également sur la
mutualisation de la dette alors que la
pandémie a durement touché le vieux
continent tensions entre londres et
moscou le gouvernement britannique
accuse la russie d'ingérence dans les
élections générales de 2010 neuf mais
aussi d'être derrière des attaques
menées par des hackers pour s'emparer de
recherche concernant un vaccin contre le
bruit 19
une accusation vivement démenties par la
rue
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france ravi de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle édition
après plus de trois heures de
concertation les partenaires sociaux
fouet le gouvernement à matignon le
premier ministre a affirmé sa volonté
est de repousser de plusieurs mois la
concertation sur la réforme des
retraites et celle de l'assurance
chômage
autre dossier évoqué le plan de relance
ou encore l'emploi des jeunes
un rendez vous capital pour fixer l
agenda social ont fait le point avec
notre reporter katia pique nique devant
l'hôtel de matignon
la conférence du dialogue social
souhaité par le premier ministre s'est
achevée peu avant 13 heures elle
réunissait plusieurs ministres dont la
ministre du travail
elisabeth bornes les syndicats les
partenaires sociaux alors jean castex
est dit satisfait de ces échanges il a
loué les qualités de responsabilité des
partenaires sociaux et surtout
évidemment le bilan très attendu et que
les concertations concernant les
réformes attendrait comme le souhaitait
d'ailleurs les syndicats à leur premier
dossier épineux l'assurance chômage
un premier volet était entré en vigueur
en novembre un second devait entrer en
vigueur en septembre ç'avait été reculé
à cause de la crise du coronavirus et
bien finalement la nouvelle échéance est
porté à 2021
je vous propose d'écouter jean castex à
ce sujet
la réforme de l'assurance chômage est
une bonne réforme et nous la mènerons à
terme mais nous avons parce que nous
sommes pragmatiques décidé de l'adapter
aux circonstances
concernant le dossier explosif des
retraites est bien là aussi les
discussions attendant on sait que les
syndicats ne voulaient pas en entendre
parler ni cet été
la rentrée mais le patronat également
s'était aligné sur cette décision
alors crise oblige et négociations
attendront on écoute jean castex
l'instauration d'un nouveau régime de
retraite universel sur lequel monsieur
le président de la république s'est
engagé en 2010 est devant le peuple
français sera maintenu simplement comme
je lé indiqué aux partenaires sociaux
nous lui appliqueront une nouvelle
méthode d'abord en distinguant très
clairement le caractère structurel de
cette réforme qui vise à plus de justice
de tous ses éléments financiers
en reprenant la concertation dans les
mois à venir pour en améliorer le
contenu et la lisibilité par nos
concitoyens
c'est une affaire extrêmement importante
alors est-ce reculer pour mieux sauter
en tout cas jean castex a bien réaffirmé
vouloir mener à bien ses réformes qu'il
juge nécessaire il a expliqué que des
divergences surviendront mais qu'elles
étaient le lot de la démocratie sociale
en tout cas pour lui la priorité à
l'heure actuelle et la relance
la priorité
et l'emploi en tout cas voilà comment
s'est conclue cette journée des changes
entre le premier ministre et les
partenaires sociaux
jean castex a en outre annoncé une autre
journée de conférence sociale en octobre
des annonces qui n'ont pas manqué de
faire réagir du côté des syndicats
écouter benoît martin secrétaire général
de la cgt paris cette détente du
calendrier évidemment peut nous
satisfaire
mais donc il n'ya pas de passage en
force qui était un temps de concertation
pourquoi pas mais sur le fond nous
restons opposés à la réforme à la fin
des séances chômage et à la réforme des
retraites
un monsieur de le foie avait quand même
pratiqué une concertation pendant 27
mois et ce départ la durée forcément de
la concertation qui donne un résultat
satisfaisant c'est bel et bien le
contenu d'un texte qui est proposé aux
syndicats puis après aux parlementaires
et donc nous ne nous ne voulons toujours
pas bien entendu de retraite par points
de même que déjà la concernant la cire
au chômage le premier volet qui avait
été mis en oeuvre en novembre dernier a
produit déjà des effets et nous voulons
également le retrait de cette première
partie de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
car les effets sont pros du produit par
cette réforme
ce sera quand même des chômeurs moins
bien indemnisés et un certain nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi qui disparaissent
des écrans radars de pôle emploi
énième rebondissement dans la sphère
adama traoré les juges d'instruction
parisiens en charge de l'enquêté sur la
mort du jeune homme de 24 ans décédé en
juillet à 2016 ont encore donné de
nouvelles investigations sans trait sur
son passé ainsi que sur celui des
gendarmes ils ont ainsi accepté
certaines demandes de l'avocat de la
famille traoré
on voit ça avec kirill kotick off
l'avantagé est de nouveau à la famille
traoré la semaine dernière les
magistrats avaient décidé de confier une
nouvelle expertise médicale à quatre
médecins belges à une décision dont
s'était félicité la défense désormais il
s'agit de fouiller un peu plus dans le
passé des gendarmes les jeux
l'instruction veulent savoir s'ils
avaient des antécédents judiciaires et
souhaite que des dossiers administratifs
soit constitué le but déterminer s'il
existait ou non un contentieux entre
adama traoré et les trois représentants
des forces de l'ordre
comprendre le jeune homme at il était
mis en cause dans d'autres affaires
commis d'autres délits pour lesquels ces
mêmes gendarmes seraient intervenus
d'une façon ou d'une autre
l'avocat de la famille traoré m yassine
bouzrou voulait une reconstitution des
faits il faudra attendre l'issue de la
fameuse expertise médicale dont les
conclusions ne sont pas attendues avant
janvier 2021
une décision qui semblerait-il est loin
de lui plaire nous constatons qu'après
quatre années d'inertie et de
manifestations dénonçant le déni de
justice
les juges ont depuis le rassemblement
devant le palais de justice du 2 juin
2020 ordonné 16 actes d'investigation à
une expertise médicale confié à des
médecins étrangers
les avocats des gendarmes défendent eux
la thèse de l'hyperthermie la
température d'adama traoré était de 39 2
2 heures après son décès un jour de
grande canicule
il se base également sur les
déclarations d'un témoin chez qui le
jeune homme se serait réfugié maître
bouzrou souhaitait aussi que l'enquêté
soit confiée à la brigade criminelle
celle ci restera finalement dans les
mains de l'inspection générale de la
gendarmerie nationale et en attendant
d'éventuels nouveaux rebondissements le
collectif justice pour adama coûte bien
poursuivre ses actions durant cet été
samedi une marche ainsi qu'un festival à
damas en l'honneur du jeune homme seront
organisées à beaumont sur oise au nord
de paris
à trois mois du nouveau référendum sur
l'indépendance de la nouvelle calédonie
les tensions politiques se cristallisent
de nombreux actes de vandalisme ont eu
lieu le week-end dernier une bâche aux
couleurs de la france notamment été
partiellement brûlés les détails avec la
nuque en 2018 56 67% des votants avaient
répondu nombreux à la proposition
d'indépendance le 4 octobre prochain les
habitants de nouvelle calédonie seront
de nouveau appelés aux yeux
en eux pour se prononcer sur
l'indépendance de l'archipel
ce référendum rentre dans le cadre de
l'accord de nouméa signé en 1998 et qui
envisage notamment l'avenir
institutionnel de la nouvelle-calédonie
deux parties s'opposent historiquement
indépendantistes et anti
indépendantistes un nouveau vote qui
n'inquiète pas particulièrement les élus
locaux favorables à l'indépendance
même si certains évoquent quelques
tensions via les réseaux sociaux
la plupart se disent sereins l'ambiance
on allait dire que les semaines à part
quelques accrochages qui ont eu lieu ce
week-end par rapport à une bâche à la
province sud
mais nous nous allons certainement nous
les indépendantistes à ce deuxième
rendez vous inscrit dans les accords de
nouméa pas on sent quand même que dans
les débats
ça se corse notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux ensemble beaucoup de deux
polémiques sur
à vision que l'on a de de la
consultation pour le oui
le 4 octobre mais nous on pense qu'il
n'y a pas du tout question de d'être
contre la france c'est simplement comme
dessiner un nouvel avenir et bien sûr de
voir les nouveaux liens au contraire que
l'on peut tisser avec l'état français
pour les partisans du non rester
français est une réelle chance pour la
population on sent que les partis sont
mobilisés des deux côtés j'ai la
conviction que la france est une chance
pour tous les calédoniens et y compris
pour les kanaks indépendantistes puisque
la chance apporte non seulement la
liberté mais garanti
les cultures non selon garantie mais
promouvoit également les cultures et en
particulier la cure toute la culture
kanak
les citoyens de l'archipel sont quant à
eux plus partagés et la place pour tout
le monde ici on peut tous ensemble
j'espère que ça sera le nom pour
l'indépendance on va rester français et
que ben il ya des petits mouvements mais
bon j'espère que ça va s'arranger
voilà il ya de la place pour tout le
monde on peut vivre tous ensemble
même propos avec les deux drapeaux je
sais pas trop c'est dur de voir le port
et le compte dans l'es2 enfin le ski et
le mieux parce que je pense que chaque
partie à quelque chose d'intéressant
enfin les deux réponses of quelque chose
ailleurs l'intérêt sans nouvelle
calédonie mais il reste donc un peu
moins de trois mois aux habitants de
nouvelle calédonie pour faire leur choix
histoire d'apaiser les tensions
actuelles pour pierre christophe pons
docteur en géopolitique chercheur
associé à l'université de la nouvelle
calédonie les résultats du deuxième
référendum devrait être semblable au
premier
au final ça fait 30 ans que on a eu des
élections provinciales qui ont un peu
donner le pouls un peu de cette de 7,2
ce rapport de force entre
indépendantistes et non indépendantiste
et on s'est bien rendu compte avec le
dernier référendum que savait pas
changer beaucoup de choses dans ce
rapport de forces est concrètement on
peut s'attendre à ce qu'au second c'est
référendum à plus de deux ans après le
premier référendum qu'on est assez peu
de changement par rapport à ce rapport
de force qui est ancrée qui est
cristallisé depuis une trentaine
d'années on voit mal un indépendantiste
changer d'avis du jour au lendemain et
al'inverse on voit mal un non
indépendantiste changer d'avis en tout
cas c'est quelque chose sur lequel on
peut s'attendre c'est qui est très peu
de changements entre le premier et le
second référendum
un sommet européen décisif à bruxelles
c'est la première fois que les 27
dirigeants de l'union européenne se
réunissent physiquement depuis la crise
du corona virus un moment de vérité pour
emmanuel macron deux jours pour se
mettre d'accord sur le plan de relance
de l'économie du vieux continent les
pays dits frigo autriche pays bas
danemark et suède veulent que ce plan
daide massif de 750 milliards d'euros
dont 500 milliards de subventions qui ne
seront pas remboursés par les états
bénéficiaires soit conditionnée à un
certain nombre de règles des discussions
très difficiles les pour angela merkel
la chancelière allemande sommes réunis
ici pour la première fois pour discuter
de la reconstruction de l'économie face
à la crise financière actuelle
notre dernier sommet on février n'a pas
été couronné de succès il ya eu beaucoup
de préparatifs et nous ne sommes pas au
même endroit qu'ont février
c'est pourquoi il nous engageons dans
les consultations avec beaucoup de
vigueur mais je dois également dire que
les différences sont encore très très
importante et je ne peux donc pas
prédire si nous serons en mesure de
parvenir à un accord cette fois-ci
l'allemagne ainsi que la france bien sûr
prêteront main-forte président du
conseil de l'union européenne charles
michel qui a travaillé très dur à la
préparation de ce sommet nous devons
maintenant mettre au travail
une fois de plus le couple franco
allemand est en première ligne de ce
conseil européen c'est ce que rappelle
gilbert casasus professeur en études
européennes
c'est la volonté de tirer les leçons de
la crise du coroner virus mais surtout
d'aller vers en avant de vouloir mener
une politique courageuse et il faut
quand même souligner on l'a fait dans la
presse française on n'a pas toujours
fait dans d'autres pays
l'énorme concessions que vient de faire
le gouvernement du berlin la chancelière
angela merkel dac et d'accepter de la
mutualisation de la dette s'étend une
avancée extraordinaire et très marquante
de l'histoire dans l'ue
de l'union européenne cette étape
décisive est parce qu une étape décisive
et bien tout simplement il faut la
gagner la logique allemande qui était
une logique d'austérité est beaucoup
plus proche actuellement de la logique
française qui est une logique
d'intervention et de dead pour que
l'union européenne les membres de
l'union en pleine puisse sortir plus ou
moins indemne de cette crise économique
qui m'est très grasse le royaume uni
accuse la russie d'interférence dans sa
campagne pour les élections générales de
fin à 2019 et de cyberattaques visant sa
recherche en matière de vaccins anti
copé 19 réaction de moscou qui souligne
le manque de preuve de telles
accusations
les détails il marre aussi d'après le
gouvernement britannique moscou aurait
cherché à interférer dans les élections
législatives au royaume uni londres
accusent des acteurs russes d'avoir
obtenu des documents de façon illégale
et de s'en être servi pour provoquer un
mouvement de protestation sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien nous sommes
maintenant en mesure de dire que nous
pensons savoir avec une confiance
raisonnable que les acteurs russes ont
été impliqués dans des tentatives d'
interférer avec les élections de 2010 9
principalement en essayant de diffuser
d'amplifier en ligne des documents
divulgués obtenues illégalement en
relation avec des négociations de
libre-échange entre le royaume uni et
les etats unis
une enquête pénale est en cours je ne
peux donc pas en dire plus les
accusations d'ingérence aussitôt rejetée
par le kremlin
la porte parole de la diplomatie russe
demande d'ailleurs des faits et des
preuves
ces déclarations sont formulées dans des
termes tellement vagues et sont
tellement contradictoires qu'elles
deviennent pratiquement incompréhensible
s'il ne convient pas d'en parler alors
n'en parlait pas si vous en parlez alors
fournissez des éléments de preuve
illégaux à litière taupe les divinités
fois absence de preuve jusqu'à présent
pour corroborer ces soupçons ingèrent
avancée par le gouvernement britannique
pas de preuve non plus dans une autre
accusation de londres liées cette fois
ci aux recherches du vaccin ou du
traitement contre le coronavirus d'après
l'organisme gouvernemental britannique
chargé de la cybersécurité moscou aurait
apporté son soutien à des pirates
informatiques
des hackers qui s'en serait pris à des
organisations britanniques canadiennes
et américaines pour tenter de voler les
recherches sur la mise au point d'un
vaccin
le kremlin dément une nouvelle fois ces
accusations la russie n'a rien à voir
avec les attaques de pirates
informatiques contre les sociétés
pharmaceutiques et les centres de
recherche au royaume uni les relations
entre londres et moscou se sont
dégradées depuis un moment notamment
depuis la sphère d'empoisonnement de
l'ancien agent russe sergueï skripal
la russie a toujours démenti son
implication et les présumés preuves
n'ont jamais été publiquement dévoilée
par le royaume uni et pour karine berger
golovkov professeur invité à
l'université d'état de moscou accusé
régulièrement la russie permet de
fédérer contre moscou les états du bloc
atlantiste et côté nous sommes toujours
dans le cas d'un tribunal médiatico
politique contre la russie qui sert à
continuer à construire la figure de
l'ennemi
le rôle de la russie et celui en quelque
sorte du méchant qui va permettre de
consolider les chantiers entre eux qui
ont entre eux un certain nombre de
divergences donc accusé la russie c'est
très pratique pour maintenir une
certaine solidarité factice entre les
différents états qui font partie du bloc
atlantiste à différents niveaux
il existe effectivement comme vous le
dites d'autres hackers en chine etc mais
géopolitiquement le combat entre les
etats-unis et la chine n'est pas un
combat politique c'est un combat que
mercy est un combat économique avec la
russie le combat est politique c'est la
question de l'existence du monde global
atlantique parce que mon globale ne peut
être que atlantique il peut n'y avoir
qu'un centre politique et la russie est
dangereuse en contestant l'existence de
cette unité du centre politique
à chaque jour son inquiétant record aux
etats unis plus de 68 nouveaux cas de
contamination ont été recensés ces
dernières 24 heures le courant des virus
poursuit sa progression aux états unis
la floride la californie et le texas
sont les états aient les plus touchées
si on dénombre plus de cent trente-huit
mille morts à travers le pays
les mesures de restrictions sanitaires
font l'objet d'affrontements politiques
entre républicains et démocrates
hier le gouverneur de géorgie a décidé
de poursuivre en justice la mère
d'atlanta il lui reproche d'avoir imposé
le port du masque aux habitants l'élu de
son côté n'entend pas reculer écoutez je
n'ai pas peur que la ville soit
poursuivi et je mettrai nos politiques
contre quiconque n'importe quel jour de
la semaine le gouverneur a pris une
position officielle sur les masques dans
l'état de géorgie quelle que soit la
motivation je pense que nous devons tous
faire la bonne chose à faire ce que les
scientifiques nous disent c'est que la
bonne chose à faire est de porter un
masque
ce que les professionnels de la santé
nous disent c'est qu'ils sont débordés
dans nos hôpitaux
deuxième pays le plus impacté par le coc
u19 derrière les états unis et le brésil
la barre des 2 millions de cas a été
franchi
la transmission du virus a atteint un
plateau
c'est ce qu'a déclaré aujourd'hui le ms
ce chiffre de 2 millions pourraient être
inférieures à la réalité en raison du
manque de test derrière bolt son héros
lui même infecté par le courant d'un
virus torres opposé au confinement ce
qui provoque l'incompréhension de
nombreux représentants politiques dont à
l'ex ministre de la santé
il n'y a pas de politique claire pour
aider la population à éviter le virus
oui en revanche nous avons un chef de
nations qui a nié la maladie qui a
incité la population à aller dans la rue
à ne pas respecter l'isolément à ne pas
respecter de l'éloignement social créant
au brésil des promesses de faux
médicaments dont l'efficacité n'est pas
prouvée scientifiquement
la militarisation du ministère de la
santé a empêché le gouvernement fédéral
de diriger la politique pour habiliter
les maires et les gouverneurs à prendre
une décision je pense que la situation
est pire maintenant que le pays a
atteint près de 2 millions de cas
confirmés nouveau bilan mais aussi
nouvelles mesures on va faire le point
sur l'évolution de la pandémie de kobe
19 dans le monde avec ce sujet hélène
masculine barcelone
confiné suite à une hausse des cas de
kovy 19 près de 4 millions d'habitants
sont appelés à rester chez eux ces deux
prochaines semaines
le gouvernement régional a interdit les
réunions de plus de 10 personnes dans
toute l'agglomération
tout comme les visites dans les maisons
de retraite il a aussi limité la
capacité d'accueil des bars et
restaurants à 50%
en effet ces dernières 24 heures ce sont
1300 nouveaux cas qui ont été détectés
en catalogne
les citoyens de 36 municipalités doivent
rester chez eux dès qu'ils ne leur est
pas indispensable de sortir
c'est la consigne que nous donnons ils
dépendent de vous tous que la contagion
ne se propage pas et nous vous
recommandons dans cette mesure également
de ne pas vous déplacer dans des
résidences secondaires pendant ce
week-end en israël également retour des
restrictions pour le week end jusqu'à
dimanche matin restaurants salles de
sport coiffeur grandes surfaces
bibliothèque ou encore muse et resteront
fermés les plages elles aussi seront
fermés tous les week-ends à compter du
24 juillet des mesures que le
gouvernement de benyamin nétanyahou
qualifie d'intermédiaire afin d'éviter
un confinement général
les mesures que nous présentons les
recommandations portent principalement
sur la façon d'arrêter les
rassemblements d'empêcher les
rassemblements dans les espaces fermés
de plus de 10 personnes et de plus de 20
dans les espaces ouverts
ce n'est pas scientifique
il y a toujours des exceptions cependant
c'est notre décision afin d'empêcher ces
rassemblements
l'alternative aux mesures que nous
prenons aujourd'hui seraient des mesures
beaucoup plus dures à prendre demain
ce que nous essayons d'éviter il se
pourrait que nous n'ayons pas le choix
et que nous devions les prendre mais
pour le moment nous tentons de prendre
des décisions rapides et conjointes en
inde
un million de personnes sont désormais
infecté malgré la multiplication des
restrictions sanitaires le pays déplore
plus de 25 mille morts depuis le début
de la pandémie
quant au bilan des décès quotidiens ils
continuent de grimper et s'établit à
plusieurs centaines 700 morts ont été
enregistrés pour la seule journée de
jeudi
le nombre de cas en inde augmentent très
rapidement
ce vendredi nous avons 35 mille nouveaux
cas en une seule journée c'est bien sûr
tout le monde a très peur samedi un
puissant parce que tout ce qui doit être
fait ne peut l'être que par des
gouvernements ou par des médecins
un million de cas en langue c'est
vraiment effrayant et inquiétant
j'espère que les choses vont être
contrôlés qu'ils vont trouver des
médicaments rapidement et qu'ils seront
disponibles pour tout le monde
en chine un nouveau foyer a été repéré
dans la région du xinjiang au nord-ouest
du pays où réside la minorité musulmane
ouïghoure la capitale régionale urumqi
qui compte trois millions et demi
d'habitants a fermé son métro tandis que
le nombre de liaisons aériennes avec la
métropole a été fortement réduit à
melbourne en australie le nombre de cas
s'envole la deuxième ville du pays a
enregistré plus de 400 nouveaux cas en
24 heures jeudi un chiffre inédit depuis
fin mars en dépit du rpt confinement
décidé il ya plus d'une semaine
à ce jour la pandémie a fait plus de 590
milles morts dans le monde quant au
nombre de cas officiellement
diagnostiqué
il est de plus de 13 8 millions dans 196
pays et territoires finie la source de
nouvelles tensions géopolitiques en
cause de le grand barrage de la
renaissance construit par l'ethiopie et
dont le remplissage vient de débuter
amarrage qui provoquerait une réduction
du débit du nil et donc des pressions
sur l'agriculture égyptienne à la verse
addis abeba à contis ray plus de 700
millions d'euros par an de la vente de
l'électricité produite par les ouvrages
les deux pays échouent depuis près d'une
décennie a trouvé un accord notamment
concernant le délai de remplissage du
barrage et est la gestion de l'eau
écoutez l'analyse est de morad el hattab
géopolitologue les intentions d'ethiopie
est une forme diderot l'hégémonie et en
ce sens l'ethiopie peut jouer un rôle
des plus importants dans l'avenir par
rapport à la distribution aussi
l'électricité
c'est pourquoi vous avez évoqué
effectivement l'egypte mais aussi le
soudan le soudan qui paraît comme j ai
depuis dix ans demande une gestion mixte
afin de pouvoir bénéficier de prix des
tristes est moindre il ya pratiquement
100 millions personnes en egypte qui
vont se retrouver pratiquement privés
d'eau c'est pourquoi il est question du
remplissage en aval de ce barrage mais
je tiens à vous dire
vous êtes face à une prochaine guerre de
l'eau qui va se dérouler sous nos yeux
vous avez en réduction en afrique ce qui
se passe entre le tibet la chine
les égyptiens n'admettront jamais que
ceux qui tiennent le robinet soit les
éthiopiens on termine ce journal avec
cette enquête visant mohammed ben zayed
al nahyan prince héritier d'abou dhabi
une affaire confiée à un juge
d'instruction français
elle concerne une éventuelle complicité
d'actes de torture sur son de guerre au
yémen selon l' afp
à savoir qu'une information judiciaire
avait déjà été ouverte en octobre
dernier à paris à l'encontre de celui
qui est surnommé mbz voilà c'est la fin
de cette édition prochain point sur
l'actualité dans un peu plus de trente
minutes
en attendant restez avec nous sur arte
france
[Musique]
[Rires]
et
[Musique]
le fait que nous avons eu ce problème de
la pandémie qui a été mondiale va amener
d'autres façons de faire des affaires et
les choses vont beaucoup se concentrer
sur l'humain et sur l'environnement
partout en afrique les présidents
prennent conscience qu'il faut vraiment
se réindustrialiser et là je pense que
david va permettre à cette
réinitialisation cela ne veut pas dire
qu'on ne doit plus commercer mais
remercié de manière différents qui
permettent à tout un chacun d'avoir un
travail décent un salaire décent
je pense que le salaire qui permet de
vivre ça c'est le plus encore
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]